I think which writers we started to wrap
our head around the idea we've got a set
of what works what doesn't
okay but they say I'm gonna give to you
is a little tool which will help you to
visualize the scene and particularly to
compare with them and later on to work
with them okay so make yourself a little
subheading okay and the subheading is
the number line okay
raise your hand if you've heard or seen
the number line before yeah I'm assuming
Mississippi of not so what I'd like you
to do is to get out of ruler now a
fortunately I do not have one that's big
yeah that'd be better better than so
what I want you to do with your rule lot
probably don't the width of your page
would be great actually
okay so rule yourself a horizontal line
and in the middle of the line I want you
to put a little vertical bonking okay
and we put one there now this is
interesting I'm glad we had such a
debate about zero because there's some
ways you could almost say zero is the
most important integer oh that's a bit
cool let's see if we can justify him now
there's a few more label on him yeah
question
not yet we'll get to it I want to let
him sit your headphones now r20
most of you have grid books but even if
you don't that's okay use your ruler and
I want you to put some even Spacey's on
here a few more markings the face for
something like this that's about all
that space for now for now we're gonna
put in all of the markings okay later on
we'll learn about tons of what you don't
need to it's a bit over the top but for
now let's mark you all of the integers
now as I do to the right I've got these
integers okay see they're increasing in
size now let me pose a question to you
don't shout at me inside just think
about it first
how long am I gonna be able to go in
this direction before the integers stop
how many integers are there how far can
I go
nothing all right now so I know records
they have the answer in the middle
they're gonna go forever there is an
infinite number of integers put a limit
set up 50 million that's all you do
random sorry okay
so therefore I do number line why don't
you conclude
is encouraged on the end which indicates
yeah they keep on going they never end
it's not like for balancing with
addition okay so they go on forever
question I'm gonna give you the answer
door and I'll explain why I laid up but
I'm gonna train it's downtown okay so
you have zero or one two three four okay
however I must show up the left hand
side here there's a reason why I put 0
in the middle we've noticed that um
you've got these kinds of numbers in
here okay so we should put them on our
number line as well like so okay so
these are the negative numbers so I'm
going to have just like before how far
do these numbers go yep yeah they also
go forever so the number line stretches
on forever in both directions okay now
this is really important to get you
might like to leave a lot to you these
numbers over here 1 2 3 4 and so on
they're the positive numbers positive
integers
okay where is therefore the left-hand
side you got the negative integers now
the positive integers you might have
learnt a name for them early on if you
use it go okay these are often cold
because of you just one two three four
and so on
actually does anyone know they've got a
couple of different names so you take
this they also known as the counting
numbers because that's what you use and
again they're also known as the natural
numbers even though there are a whole
bunch of other numbers that come up in
nature black pine which we'll get onto
later but that's the name that's getting
together has been given to it now quick
question
zero quick return zero a lot is it
positive or negative
the answer is pulled by a bit of a bit
of a load off he's there he's not
positive or negative
but in some ways you know that makes it
even more special so I'm zero zero is
not positive or negative still part of
you teachers okay but it doesn't really
belong in either visa sense all right
now suppose we wanted to put some
numbers on to here here's the way that
you mark in here's an important number
here's something which I wanna note you
want to put a big field circle on the
number line okay
so pay attention don't you this okay you
don't want to have your big circle up
here you don't want it sort of floating
off in between your numbers okay you
want to have it all on the number line
subway like for instance there's - yes
just leave him on that um
so I'd like you to mark it on your
number line just like I have marking -
two for me okay and you might like to
label it a filled circle or the line
okay so likewise that's how we put them
on your but if you saw that marking
you'd be able to read it back as well if
you put something like this that you'd
be able to say that that's all right
now that's it's sort of the start we're
going to use the number line is a really
powerful tool which we're going to use
I'm gonna give you an exercise to sort
of get a handle on but before I do one
last little thing you notice that here
in another line you have a left and a
right okay so because these integers
right
unlike the counting numbers or the
natural numbers integers have a
direction okay they can be negative or
they can be positive okay
negative might be left and positive
might mean right or negative my main
down or positive might be up what other
kinds of things could negative and
positive signify any takers what else
could it be yeah yeah
how bad is it wow that dinner was minus
60 okay that's terrible food poisoning
all right yeah
oh good yeah so so no okay how about
something with money
you did something some work on money
your previous success what could they be
what might you do with Michael you might
have one direction and it's opposite yep
yeah good so we draw or we draw and
what's the opposite of taking money out
putting money in his deposit isn't it
okay good now question how do you tell
which one of these it is we could go on
for ages it's over an early fire right
how can you tell what plus or minus
positive or negative actually means like
if you just saw plus five does it mean
up five right five or five closed doors
I'll tell you this one because it's a
bit tricky and actually we can write
this for them the answer is at the
permit you can't tell it's not enough
information okay but what you can use to
tell and I want you to have this written
on again okay you can tell what positive
or negative mean
he's a big word for you
that's a context okay excellent
did you catch that let me say it again
context means there's gonna be Frizzles
forward you might have a sentence or
four sentence you might have a paragraph
or you can have something surrounding
your information which helps you know
what that particular information means
so example what does beat me my daughter
asked me this the other day what does
beat me and the answer is tell me the
context what could it mean what things
could eat me
oh yeah okay be forward go through go
through like this this bush land their
way to beat through this okay yep
perfect an art it could be a it could be
a drum beat okay another one yep okay
you could you could I'm running out of
space you could
don't pack on it you pack up my tiny
teeth and that will be fun
you can hurt someone you could beat them
in a race you could beat some eggs you
get the idea context will tell you